what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we're going to be talking
about the Fantastic Four specifically
the cast of The Fantastic Four who are
we going to see play Reed Richards Sue
storm Johnny Storm and Ben Grimm finally
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe it's
looking like we could see some big names
some not so big names and some familiar
names that could play The Fantastic Four
but not in the way that you think we
also do sort of get an update about the
X-Men casting from this Fantastic Four
update as well so of course we're going
to be talking about the X-Men today as
well we know that Marvel Studios right
now is working as hard as they can to
develop this Fantastic Four movie we
know it means a lot to Kevin feige the
president of Marvel Studios he has
already expressed how excited he is to
have Marvel's first family enter the
Marvel Cinematic Universe plus not to
mention he worked on the previous
Fantastic Four films as well in the past
so this means a great deal to him so you
know he's going to put everything he has
into this movie but who is he going to
get to play The Fantastic Four
characters this is an extremely
important decision that is going to
affect the future of the MCU for years
and years to come because we know that
once the Fantastic Four enter the MCU
they're not going anywhere anytime soon
they're around for the long run which
were all very very excited for and it
looks like a pretty big actor is in the
Run for the Fantastic Four's Human Torch
most of you have probably at least seen
him if you haven't heard of him but
Austin Butler who recently played Elvis
in the movie Elvis him and his
management team are currently
campaigning for him to play the Human
Torch now Austin Butler has been in
Hollywood and the movie and TV scene for
a pretty long time one of his first
acting gigs was actually in Hannah
Montana in 2006. he then went on to play
a key character in Zoe 101 so he's
pretty familiar with Disney now of
course he's done a lot more since 2006
and he might even go on to win an Oscar
for his performance in Elden us Elvis
was a huge movie it was a massive
success and of course he's been in other
big movies as well such as Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood with Leonardo DiCaprio
and Brad Pitt and according to a recent
report his agents are putting him up for
the role of the Human Torch recently
Kevin feige has said that there is
currently no cast currently on board for
the Fantastic Four that is going to be
written by Matt shackman now he could be
lying of course it's not really a lie he
can't just say what is going on behind
the scenes at Marvel Studios after all
he's the president and he's very good at
keeping spoilers I'm not sure Kevin
feige has ever really spoiled anything
but make no mistake the Fantastic Four
cast has been narrowed down and they're
pretty close to making a decision and
I'm pretty sure Kevin feige already
knows who he wants if not he knows at
least a couple of people who would be
right for each role but according to
Jeff Snyder on the hot mic podcast he
stated that Butler's agents were putting
him up for the Human Torch as Marvel
starts casting for the 2025 Fantastic
Four film he also went on to say that
two crown jewels are coming up so all
the actors in town want to be a part of
these two franchises speaking of the
Fantastic Four and the X-Men now we have
a lot more to talk about but here's the
big question that I want to hear from
you all about will Austin Butler make a
good Human Torch slash Johnny Storm for
those of you who have seen his acting
skills and have possibly seen him
outside of Elvis because Elvis is a
completely different character from The
Human Torch what do you think about
Austin Butler playing the Human Torch
I'm sure he would do an excellent job
but do you think he fits the part that
is the question let me know what you
think in the comments down below now
we've also kind of got a little bit of a
disappointing update recently as far as
John krasinski's Mr Fantastic goes I
know a lot of people really want John
Krasinski to play Mr Fantastic I am one
of those people especially after seeing
him in Multiverse of madness he was
pretty much perfect except he didn't end
up being that smart because he simply
just reached for the Scarlet Witch which
really wasn't the smartest move and
resulted in him being turned into string
cheese hopefully he is smarter in our
universe I'm just on the phone with this
stupid salesman he's so dumb
probably just going to keep him on the
line forever and not buy anything but
unfortunately John Krasinski has
revealed that he's only had really one
talk with Marvel Studios about playing
Mr Fantastic and that was for Multiverse
of Madness however he recently said
something very interesting that leads us
to believe that he is indeed done with
the character in a recent interview he
said there aren't any discussions at all
the only discussion I had was actually
in the second to last week of Jack Ryan
Kevin feige called and said would you
ever fly to LA and play in our sandbox
for a day I was honored to do it I flew
right from Budapest when we wrapped and
went right to the doctor strange set I'm
a big fan of all those characters in
that world so to get to play in that
sandbox for a day was a real thrill it
was totally insane to be in a room with
all those people and again to be a part
of that narrative is crazy but yeah
being turned into spaghetti wasn't my
end goal in life as far as how it goes
in the Marvel Universe but you know what
it was fun nonetheless what's
interesting here is that he says the end
goal he said says he hasn't had any
further conversations with Marvel
Studios and he said that wasn't his end
goal to die and be turned into spaghetti
this implies that that was it for him as
Mr Fantastic and Kevin feige has even
spoken up about this before in the past
and based on what he said it does sound
like this was kind of a fan service and
something for it fun that they did for
Multiverse Madness kind of a one-off
thing so Krasinski most likely won't be
our main Mr Fantastic in the MCU however
he could return in secret Wars because
we know a ton of variants are going to
pop up in that movie and although one of
his variants did die there of course has
to be other variants out there that look
exactly like John Krasinski so don't
write him off completely just yet and of
course there's always the fact that they
sign ndas so even if he was cast as Mr
Fantastic there's no way he could say
anything at all in fact him and his wife
Emily Blunt could be playing Mr
Fantastic in The Invisible Woman and we
could have zero idea whatsoever however
we are about two years away almost from
the movie which means the cast is going
to be locked down pretty soon so they
can start pre-production and then
eventually start filming and here's the
other thing Kevin feige has been casting
for the Fantastic Four and the X-Men for
years now ever since the fox Disney
acquisition took place Kevin feige has
been meeting with actors randomly about
possible roles for the X-Men and Kevin
feige does this all the time not just
for the X-Men not just for the Fantastic
Four but for characters in general and
sometimes he meets with actors and
actresses not for a specific role but
just to talk about them joining the MCU
and sometimes he'll meet with them for
years until they finally decide on a
roll or not sometimes they never
actually find a role for an actor to
play many of you are probably aware of
the Jake Gyllenhaal story they met with
Jake for years before he was finally
cast as Mysterio before they finally
agreed hey this is the perfect role for
Jake Gyllenhaal and he agreed and that's
how he got the role for Mysterio but we
know he's met with other actors and
nothing has ever came of it so as far as
we're concerned right now the Fantastic
forecast is pretty much almost done and
the X-Men are being looked at right now
now the most recent rumored Fantastic
Four casting list at least for Mr
Fantastic and The Invisible Woman are
concerned is pinned Badgley for Mr
Fantastic and Jody Comer for the
invisible woman most of you know her
from the movie free guy she plays the
main actress and I'm still for this
casting I really like it if we're not
going to be getting Krasinski and blunt
because they truly are my first choice
but pin Badgley and Jody Comer are
really good choices and they are younger
so for trying to start off with a new
Young Fantastic Four it's a pretty good
choice and it looks like that decision
is about to be made because we have
recently learned from the director of
Ant-Man and the WASP Peyton read that
the Fantastic Four pre-production is
well underway in a recent interview he
has actually stated that he has seen the
initial artwork for the Fantastic Four
around the Marvel office and for those
of you who are not aware Payton Reed has
wanted to make a Fantastic Four movie of
his own for over 20 years and he helped
get the first Fantastic Four movie from
Fox off the ground so he has been been
working with the Fantastic Four since
2001 a couple of years before the first
film came out he never got the chance to
make his movie but now he's going on to
direct Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
which is going to be huge but he is a
huge Marvel fan and a huge Fantastic
Four fan and he says that the new
Fantastic Four is going to be great and
like I mentioned he said he has seen the
initial artwork so it's well underway so
the cast is probably going to be locked
down pretty soon so hopefully it's not
too much longer until we find out who
our actual fantastic forecast is going
to be now of course we are going to be
getting our main MCU Fantastic Four
before we get our X-Men that's because
we are going to see the older original
Fox X-Men characters enter rmcu before
our new X-Men entered the MCU they're
saving the new X-Men for phase 7 and
Beyond however it is going to be really
really cool to see old characters return
like Hugh Jackman's Wolverine maybe
Hollyberry storm Professor Xavier
returning again hopefully his neck
doesn't get snapped this time I'm tired
of watching him die maybe even Ian
McKellen can return turn as Magneto
anything is really possible for this
movie but I am excited to finally see
the Fantastic Four in the X-Men in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and let us
know how excited you are for this in the
comments down below and do you think
Austin Butler would make a good
fantastic Four's Human Torch let us know
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news for live
updates you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof